que faire des batteries de voiture une
fois qu'elles sont obsolètes
l'entreprise yvelinoise car watts à la
réponse à la question avec ses douze
employés elle réutilise des batteries
comme les batteries des eaux et renault
qui ne sont plus utilisables elles
peuvent garder jusqu'à 70 % de leurs
capacités
car watts répond à une demande à la fois
politique et environnemental de
transformer la société d'une énergie
carbone et en énergie décarbonée la
députée de la 10e circonscription aurore
bergé la sous-préfète de rambouillet
florence gilbert se sont déplacés pour
visiter l'entreprise
l'occasion de mettre en avant ces
startups qui dynamise le territoire on
encourage beaucoup les français
aujourd'hui à aller vers l'électrique et
aller vers des modèles qui sont moins
polluants il faut leur en donner les
moyens mais ça pose aussi la question de
l'avenir évidemment des batteries qui
sont utilisés c'est important d'avoir
des start-up déjà parce que ça montre le
dynamisme du territoire ça montre aussi
des personnes qui s'engagent et qu'ils
réfléchissent à comment mieux vivre
demain et puis bien sûr parce que tout
ça derrière ces créateurs d'emplois car
what a bénéficié du plan france relance
après avoir répondu à un appel à projet
autour de la décarbonation une
subvention de l'état à hauteur de 450
mille euros leur a été accordé un
financement qui permet de les soutenir
dans leurs projets cette entreprise a pu
bénéficier de france relance parce
qu'elle présentait un modèle qui était
un modèle nouveau innovants qui
répondent à des besoins de
transformation énergétique ça nous a
aidé à conserver un minimum d'ingénieurs
pour pouvoir déposer les brevets c'est
notre sauvegarde et puis c'est le savoir
français une économie circulaire
vertueuse dans plusieurs domaines
l'aéroportuaire les véhicules de safari
ou encore le fluvial des marchés que
l'entreprise entend bien multiplier dans
les années à venir